we've been talking about the north let's
speak to a northern conservative mp
jake berry uh he represents rosendale
and darwin that's in lancashire
uh jake principal tell us what's it like
in your constituency with covert at the
moment
we're uh over 400 per hundred thousand i
represent
two local authorities it's a mixed
picture but both of them are high
but what you have to remember is of
course tier two
which came in yesterday for my
constituents
was a relaxation of the position we have
been in
since august and during that tier 2
style lockdown that
we have had across large parts of the
north of england since august
our rates have gone up tenfold so
i think there's a healthy spoonful of
skepticism
that tier two is going to work in
lancashire so are you saying then that
the lockdown rules that you've had so
far
really haven't worked in controlling the
virus
well self-evidently they haven't based
on the number of course we don't know
what would have happened if we hadn't
have had
the tier 2 style lockdown since late
summer but what i would say is this my
impression is and i i disagree
with quite a lot of that polling because
i think it gives people a false choice
people will always choose
health over money i think anyone with a
brain
would choose that but when i go around
lancashire i talk to people and talk to
council leaders across lancashire
the impression i get very different is
that most people are
simply ignoring everything that's being
said in westminster they
aren't really paying attention to tier 1
tier 2 tier 3
they've sort of made up their own mind
how they're going to deal
with this disease they kind of comply
with what they believe
the rules are but in truth most people
don't know or understand what the rules
are it's not because we are thick
or stupid in lancashire it's because
they keep
changing and since august i think across
large parts of the north of england
we're now in our 19th
or 20th different set of rules so we
have a sort of uh self
uh imposed and decided upon lockdown
rules which people
are consistently following to try and
keep themselves safe but it's not
doesn't bear much resemblance to what
the government wants us to do in my
experience
interesting isn't the government right
to have gone
this local lock down route to have
different rules depending on the state
of covert in different regions or cities
or so on or if we wanted i saw you
you said to lbc we need simple rules and
a simple message well
right there wrongly you could say that a
national circuit breaker was that
well look the government is right to
have imposed these national restrictions
of course
we're talking about roslindale and
darwin this evening we'll be talking
about reading and dagenham in just
a couple of months time i'm sorry to say
or even a couple of weeks time
so having a national system which people
can understand and is simple
is a country mile better than the
confusing
and uh sort of you know mishmash of
rules that we've had across
the north of england but crucially and
this is where the government has got it
absolutely right this week
it needs to be turned on and off
according
to local data and that's why actually i
don't favor a national
lockdown but i would be pretty relaxed
actually about
a local circuit breaker in lancashire
because in truth
we've been in tier 2 since august it
hasn't worked
so we need not to continue what we know
doesn't work
i think we'd be up for trying something
else and our local lockdown across
lancashire
manchester and merseyside based on their
data if that's what they want
i think would be the right thing to do
from where we are today so who should
have the responsibility for deciding to
go into a
local circuit breaker well i think it
should be based on the data i mean if we
based it on data it wouldn't
fall upon the who would take the
decision called council leaders
well i've called on the government to
set a clear
gateway both in and out of lockdown
and these tiers and also to publish
information
this is sort of we're not telling people
in lancashire whether we're
doing well or badly with what we're
doing you know this test and trace app
it cannot be on the wit of man to embed
data in the test and trace up about how
we are doing
if you visit any church hall across the
country they will probably have a
thermometer
on the wall telling you how near they're
getting for their church ruth appeal
we like targets people like to know that
what they're doing is working
so i think if you had a clear and fixed
gateway where you came in and out
of tears that the decision would be made
by the data not by
local or national politicians yeah but
data doesn't take decisions data informs
decisions i'm still not quite clear
who would take this local government
or would it be national government well
it would have to be a combination of
both but if you said for example
if your rate is over four hundred
thousand per hundred thousand your
transmission rate
is over x or your hospitalization rate
is over why
it would come to a point you would then
have local and national politicians
saying
we have gone past the trigger point now
is the time for us to implement
tier three lockdown or a a circuit
breaker lockdown whatever it may be
but at least the public would then not
see this bickering between
northern labour mayors and number 10 and
ministers
they would say well actually this is
based on real science
real data that we can understand and we
are part of
therefore we support the decision i just
don't think with the current state of
decision making
that i think we've lost the public
frankly in many parts of the north of
england
has has the government then therefore
not handled the north well
well i think it certainly could have
handled the north better
i think our messaging has been poor i
think we've
as i said i think we've lost large parts
of the public's attention in the north
of england it feels to me funnily enough
a bit like
brexit felt just as we were coming up
towards the general election that we
were bickering about things
in parliament and most people i spoke to
well we won't we voted for it we don't
care how you do it
just get on with it when i talk to
people across the north of england they
say look
you know we don't want you bickering in
parliament about what's going on and
whether we should listen to our mayor
or council leader or government we just
want you
to get on with tackling this disease and
that may be a completely unreasonable
ask of the public that
it's very very difficult but it sort of
feels to me
that that's where their opinion is and
that's a very dangerous moment
for parliament and it's very dangerous
moment for these
northern mayors i think as well
could be dangerous for your party too i
mean the conservative party is now to
some extent the party of the north
since the december 2019 election you're
no longer
just the party of the leafy home
counties are you in danger with the way
the government's going about this
of uh losing the north well i think it's
far too early to
talk about losing the north but you know
there are 80
northern mps that we are literally the
prime minister's majority so he needs to
look after us bluntly but i also think
labour's in quite a lot of trouble with
this as well
because what we are now seeing is a big
division opening
between the labour mayors of the north
of england who are pushing the
government saying
every single decision should be based on
local data
and on what local politicians think and
of course kiyostama who's calling for
a national lockdown that's all very well
it may be the right thing to do in parts
of north of england to have a circuit
breaker
but what i don't want to see is when
rates go up in
cornwall or in the south of england for
the north to be pushed into another
national circuit breaker just as all the
numbers have gone down and our economy
is
starting to recover so yes i'm there is
divisions within the conservative party
but i think that
moved by kierstana this week was a
bigger mistake than we yet realize
because it's creating big division both
with him and his mps
in the north of england who many of his
mps are campaigning to have a local
approach
and of course many of these mayors who
are absolutely appearing on our tv
channels every night saying
it has to be a locally led approach
that's not what key's
suggesting and i think it's starting to
cause him some trouble and yet andy
burnham the mayor of manchester and
others seem to imply i seem to say i
take the position that they
they would rather have a national
circuit breaker as mr starmer calls it
than being placed into a tier by
central government are they right
well i don't think they are i don't
think a national circuit breaker is the
right way to go i support
many of the arguments andy burnham's
made actually i've supported him in the
comments
about we have to have local data guiding
these decisions
why should uh cornwall be put in
lockdown
now okay that's bad for cornwall now but
my real concern as i've said
is in two three months time i don't want
my constituency put back into lockdown
because they've got covert in the south
so let me just get you to sum up jake
berry
what should take your constituency in
the surrounding areas
or areas in the north that have a
similar
number of covet cases what should
the proper way ahead be as we sit here
tonight
for your area okay so the three-tiered
system
has been in now just for 24 hours the
incubation period for this disease is 14
days so we simply can't say whether this
uh
tier 2 tier 3 is going to work yet so i
think we have to give it at least
two weeks although i said there is a
large spoon of skepticism across the
north of england
because we look at many of these
restrictions say well we've had them for
over two months
and they haven't worked but i want to
give the scientists and the computer
models
the benefit of the doubt so let's give
them a fortnight
if things haven't moved by then if we
are still seeing a rapid increase
in growth rate of this disease and
transmissibility within the community
i don't think there is any other choice
for the government
except to move to some form of circuit
breaker
based on local data and i think it
should be done on a county-by-county
basis so you would choose to do
lancashire you may then choose to
greater manchester merseyside
maybe areas of west yorkshire and we go
in and out of that circuit breaker based
on local data so liverpool may be in it
for a fortnight lancashire maybe in it
for three weeks greater manchester in it
for a month
so be it but each one of those local
circuit breakers
has to be backed by proper gover
government financial support
and that's really what we're looking to
the chancellor now to come forward if we
do go into that situation
to say how the government's going to
support people and businesses throughout
what will be a
difficult and cold and miserable period
in the winter
you don't think the government's done
enough do you on that front
well i think that we should be doing
more i've
i've been quite clear that i think we
should keep the 80 wage subsidy for
those who are
low paid uh you can do that by
guaranteeing 80
of the wages up to a different level
it's currently
66.6 up to two thousand one hundred
we of course could say well you know the
first thousand or the first twelve
hundred quid
will guarantee eighty percent but we're
coming towards christmas and people
who often work in the hospitality
industry on low wages
you know we'll be feeling the pinch
already hospitality having been shut
down for much of the year
and i don't think it's unreasonable for
them to say to the government actually
we expect you to keep supporting our
wages
at 80 percent
you